[music]
>> Brother Muhammad Hisham
Muhammad
Is it Hisham? I'm Muhammad Hisham.
Ah, the same Malaysian. S Y
Hisham. Well, when I got it, I'm hearing
the name.
The African Hisham for the first time.
Good. Masha Allah.
Brother Muhammad Hisham His first
expectation is how to engage the
Westerner stroke YouTube personals to
disseminate the information as they are
the ones that engage the youth today.
Insha Allah, we'll be discussing this
topic on
Dawah through social media.
We will be covering on this subject,
insha Allah.
What are behind the scenes
with Saudi Arabia?
What are behind the scenes with Saudi
Arabia? Sorry.
I don't understand this expectation.
What do you mean by what are behind the
scenes with Saudi Arabia? I'm not a
specialist of behind the scenes of Saudi
Arabia, and neither is the Dawah
training program in any way connected to
Yes, if you say you'll get closer to the
Haramain, all good. Alhamdulillah.
Because that's the holy land the blessed
land of the two Haramain, Mecca and
Medina. But behind the scenes of Saudi
Arabia
can you explain to me? Bismillah Rahman
Rahim.
Firstly, let me explain
when I got
the request for the seven expectations,
it was roughly about two or
days before
I came over.
So, that would be roughly
uh maybe about 1:00 or 2:00 a.m. So, I
might be
sleepy.
So, uh to elaborate on that point, I
believe my point was since Saudi Arabia
holds the master key in terms of uh
economy
oil
I just want to know why
or what's the uh
main point that they are hesitant to
help the
other Muslim countries that is uh
suffering around the world.
Brother, if you want to know why Saudi
Arabia is hesitant, you have to go to
Saudi Arabia.
Or go to an expert who's done a study of
Saudi Arabia. Yes, I've been to Saudi
Arabia many times. Alhamdulillah. I've
been there more than 80 to 100
times. Masha Allah.
I've been there many times, but I'm not
a specialist in knowing behind the
scenes.
Yes. What you can learn from Saudi, I
can tell you.
What are the good points, I can tell
you.
I have not met
a community
in the world in all my travels
people who are Saudis, especially in two
aspects
Tawhid and Salah.
There is no community in the world that
I know of
and Allah has blessed me
in traveling in different parts of the
world
irrespective of what he is.
In Tawhid and Salah
you will not find a community anywhere
close to the Saudis.
He may do other wrong things. May do or
may not do secondary.
But if he's a Saudi, the chances of him
being on Tawhid
is Alhamdulillah highest, according to
me
in any Muslim country.
There may be Muslims better than them
but as a whole
in Tawhid
in Salah and the five pillars
in general.
So, this I can tell you very well
that if you want to learn something from
the Saudis
learn about Tawhid
as a whole
Salah
as a whole.
When the time for Salah is there, they
won't even wait for the king.
And one friend had gone
we had a performer, you know, that okay,
fine, we'll be offering Salah with the
king.
And the time for Salah was the Azan, we
prayed.
The king prayed where he was.
And you have that example in Obama.
You know, Obama and his wife went to
Saudi Arabia for condolence
and King Salman
when the time for Asr Salah was there
he walked away.
There's no appointment better than
appointment with Allah.
Correct?
And imagine
he's going away from the most powerful
man in the world Obama.
He knows
that compared to Allah, he's peanuts.
Not even peanuts. Saying peanuts is also
wrong, shirk.
Wrong, why? Allah says
Wa lam yakul lahu kufuwan ahad.
So, even saying peanuts is wrong.
So, I apologize. I take age of LGBT.
Insha Allah.
We may may not cover.
We may, insha Allah.
Point number four.
Showcase that there is no other belief
that informs the world of the future
events unlike Islam.
That means no other religion speaks
about the prophet like Islam. That's
what you meant.
Because that's a small
one of the points of
Dawah that can be used.
But that's not an ace.
We always prefer teaching someone with
an ace
rather than a maybe a two or a three or
a four.
Point number five. And how to confront
the elites.
Insha Allah.
Confront.
You know, Allah says in the Quran in
Surah Fussilat
chapter number 41, verse number 34.
That
you deal with people kindly so that
you win them over. You win over the
enemies, not defeat them.
When you have a match
you either defeat your enemy or win them
over. Which is better? Winning over is
better or defeating them is better?
Huh?
Winning them.
So, if you say that rather than
confronting the elites, saying
convincing the elites is a better word.
A Da'ee does it not for winning brownie
points. A Da'ee does it
for the Akhirah.
That's the reason Muhammad Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam
in his Dua, he prayed to Allah Subhana
Wa Ta'ala that out of the two men
he said at least give Hidayah to one.
And Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala gave Hidayah
to Umar Radhi Allahu Anhu. Umar bin
Khattab
may Allah be pleased with him
who was one of the staunchest enemy of
Islam became one of the strongest
supporter of Islam.
And he was one of the major factors
in the spread of Islam. That is the
reason Michael H. Hart in his book even
mentioned in the name of Umar, may Allah
be pleased with him, in the top 100
personalities.
You have given five points.
May Allah subhanahu fulfill the thing
that with
those expectations will take you to
Jannah, inshallah.
You mentioned five, there should have
been seven. The next person on my list
is brother Abdul Malik Bedagges.
Number one is strengthening Iman in
order to be more pious
and more protective
in doing activities that should always
be under the Sharia principle.
Inshallah, these things
if paid attention on the talks given
and the methodology
inshallah, it will strengthen your Iman,
inshallah.
And alhamdulillah, you'll realize that
many things you thought
are impossible with the help of Allah,
alhamdulillah, the things you thought
are impossible become possible.
Point number two, learning Islam from
the authorized Muslim scholars,
namely Dr. Zakir Naik and others.
Number one, brother Abdul Malik, I'm not
authorized.
And neither am I a scholar, I'm a
Muslim, alhamdulillah. Out of three
words,
I agree I'm a Muslim.
I don't have authority.
Allah has blessed me,
alhamdulillah, and neither do I consider
myself to be a scholar, I consider
myself to be a student, and may Allah
make it possible that I deliver his
message to as many people as possible,
inshallah. But inshallah, it will be my
pleasure.
And if you can learn something from me,
may Allah accept your efforts and my
efforts also, inshallah.
>> [music]
[music]